Okay, in this tutorial I'm going to talk
about order flow and positioning.
So, I will start this off by saying that
order flow is not a secret tool.
A lot of people are led to believe that
like it's a magical missing puzzle piece
in their trading and I'm going to tell
you the brutal honest truth. It is
absolutely not.
Narrative is is going to be the most
important thing so how you form a
narrative. So, the way I do that is with
composite structure, long-term VWAPs,
auction market theory. Order flow is
kind of like the last puzzle piece
involved in execution and I would say
it's it's about 10% of your trading. So,
I just want to preface that.
So, what I'm going to go over here is
this is what I call my execution
template on TradingView. I do use
footprint charts and other order flow
data and much more complicated stuff
than this.
Um but I do use this as well and it's
extremely useful and extremely easy to
use.
So,
a couple things I'm going to touch on
here. So, what is order flow?
Well, essentially it's it's kind of who
is in control of the market, you know,
at that time. So, you can see buyers and
sellers,
you know, where they're interacting, how
they're transacting, how aggressive they
are, right? Things like that. So,
two things I want to talk about here
is open interest and delta.
So, specifically for
crypto,
um use of open interest of course just
if you're not trading crypto just
disregard this part but nonetheless,
it all still applies.
So, open interest. So, open interest
essentially is just
the total number of open contracts or
open positions
at a certain time. So, if you see an
increase in open interest, that's
positions opening. If you see a
decrease, that would be positions
closing.
Um
delta.
Delta is since you it shows
how aggressive the market is at a
certain price point candle by candle
basis over, you know, accumulation of
time.
Uh essentially it's market buys versus
market sells.
Um so, we'll touch on that in a second.
Um there's two kind of
participants in the market. So,
there is aggressive participants, right?
They use market orders. They're kind of
chasing price.
So, like you and I.
And then you have passive participants,
right? So, that's larger limit orders.
Um
very simply, right? Bigger players in
the market providing liquidity.
Things like that.
So,
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> when it comes to this template, for
example, this is the way I built this.
So, down here I have open interest and
right here I have delta. Obviously, it's
shown on a candle-by-candle basis.
And there's a few reasons this is
important.
So, using open interest on its own,
okay? So, the way I have it shaded um
a standard open interest and delta kind
of layout that people have, whether it's
on footprint or on TradingView, other
platforms, it doesn't really matter.
Often times that they have two colors.
So, maybe delta, positive delta they
have green, negative delta they have
red. And open interest maybe green and
red. So, green is an increase and red's
a decrease. Or sometimes they use blue.
And that could be helpful.
But, it doesn't tell you how significant
the increase or decrease is open
interest or how much negative delta or
how much positive delta there is.
So, that's part of why I've made this
template so useful and so easy to use is
the way I've set it up. I have a
template in which
increases in open interest, just kind of
a standard threshold increase, is white.
A decrease is gray. A large decrease, so
five times the
or sorry, five times greater than the
average or the mean of the last X amount
of candles prior,
it gets highlighted dark red.
Conversely, if it's an increase, it's
dark green. And I have the exact same
thing with delta. So, this is delta
here.
And standard delta, right? It is your
light gray. A decrease or negative delta
is
dark gray. And then the closer it gets
to being bright green or or red, that's,
you know, larger threshold increases
from there. So, I think it goes up one
and a half times, two and a half times
multiplier, three and a half times
multiplier. So, the more significant the
delta is, the darker it is.
>> [clears throat]
>> And I've also set it up to
portray that on the candles. So, as you
see here,
right, this this large amount of
positive delta also highlighted the
candle green.
Same thing here. This is also a large
threshold increase. It's yellow. The
candle's also yellow.
So, why does this matter to you? Well,
you kind of have
a handful of things that
you can read with open interest and
delta. So, I'm going to touch on this
quickly.
A lot of people think that are familiar
with delta,
they think that delta alone tells you if
if it's selling or if it's buying. So,
on its own, it's actually not true.
And that they know that that's just not
the case. So, open interest and delta
being used together can can tell you the
whole story. So,
um
I'll explain this simply here. So, there
is market buys and market sells, right?
That's what delta is, market buys minus
market sells.
So,
when you enter a long, let's say you you
entered a buy trade, right?
You're in profit. So,
for every trader in the market, every
position, there's somebody else on the
either side on opposite side of that
trade. So, there's if every buyer
there's a seller in the market. So, if
you enter a buy trade,
and say it's in profit and you want to
close, or say it's going against you and
it hits your stop, or you close at a
loss, so let's say, you know, it goes
down.
When you close a long, you're actually
market selling.
Okay? So, you're you're now fueling the
move down. Conversely, if you entered a
sell,
or a short, rather,
and it goes up,
and you want to close it, you actually
have to market buy back.
Right? So, now you're adding positive
delta.
So, why does that matter?
Well, because there's a difference
between
longs being forced to close
and new shorts opening. They both will
show you negative delta,
but they're two different things, right?
They have different implications behind
them. Especially given market context,
they mean two different things.
And conversely,
if a move it it is buyers being flushed
out of their position, right? Instead of
new shorts, that means, you know,
conversely, if it finds support, the
same thing couldn't happen, right? So,
if it was new shorts and let's say they
bottomed around here, it starts to go
up, and then those sellers start to
exit, it would fuel the move upwards.
That's not going to happen if the move
is already fueled by buys that had to
puke their position.
So, one thing I want to touch on and
then I'll show you why that's important
on chart in a minute.
So, you have a few different sequences
when it comes to
open interest and delta. So, let me draw
this for you here really quickly.
I think
I may have
a cheat sheet for this.
If I can find it here quickly.
I know I did have it. Just a moment.
Um not sure where it is.
Let me just see. If not, I will redraw
it.
Here it is. I got it.
If it loads here.
Copy.
Here it is. Perfect. Should have had
that prepared, but that's okay.
Put that over there. Perfect. So, OI,
open interest. So, anytime open interest
has an increase, that means new
positions are opening.
Conversely, a decrease in open interest
means positions are closing. So, when
you use open interest and delta
together, it tells you the story whether
the move is fueled by new longs, for
example,
or it's new shorts,
or
it's shorts closing or longs closing,
right? They all have different
implications behind them. So, this is an
example of that. So,
an increase in open interest always
means new positions. So, an increase in
open interest with positive delta always
means new longs.
A decrease, I'm sorry, an increase in
open interest with negative delta always
means new shorts.
And a decrease in open interest is
always positions closing. So, a decrease
in OI with positive delta means shorts
closing.
Right?
And a decrease in OI with negative delta
means longs are closing.
So, that's important as well. There's a
little cheat sheet to have. You can save
that if you'd like to.
So, why does that matter?
Well, there's a few different kind of
scenarios. So, you have the idea of
absorption, exhaustion,
and what I just call a you know, a flush
or puke in open interest. So, it'd be
the same as like a
a short squeeze or a long liquidation.
It's all the same thing. It's it's all
open interest being flushed out of their
positions, right?
So, absorption. What is absorption?
Start with the first one, which is is is
probably the most favorable, and it goes
back to what I was talking about before
with positions closing versus positions
opening.
And, you know, that idea of fueling the
move in the other direction.
So, I'm going to draw this very simply.
So, let's say you have a level here, and
this goes back to both kind of
participants. So, let's say there's a
passive seller up here.
Okay? There's there's a large large
limit order up here.
And the market's trending up. Let's say
you know, aggressive participants are
looking to buy.
And let's say price hits the passive
seller's order, okay? And aggressive
buyers buy here.
Aggressive buyers not being strong
enough to break through the passive
seller's limit order,
right?
What happens when aggressive buyers are
forced to close their position? They
actually market sell.
Right? So, if you position short here,
all of the buyers up here will be forced
to close their position.
Therefore, when they close their
position, they actually market sell and
they fuel the move the other way.
So, how do you identify that? Well, what
I just showed you before, you use open
interest and delta to see.
Right? If there's an increase in open
interest with positive delta, that means
new longs. So, if you identify that at
an area of resistance,
that can potentially fuel the move down
for you where you can get short
and you'll get a move the other way.
Okay?
And I can show you what that looks like
here.
So, like I said,
this is open interest, this is delta,
right?
So, if we go along here,
see if we can find an example here
quickly.
So, this can order flow can be used over
uh you know, kind of a contextual read,
it can be used for execution. I use it
more for execution. I'm not really using
it on a
you know, a a candle-by-candle basis. Or
sorry, not a contextual basis. So, for
example here,
this is, you know, a setup that
um kind of played out yesterday.
So, obvious resistance here, so I'm not
going to break this down fully, but
obviously if you're watching this,
you've watched kind of the the videos
prior to this on
the idea of balance, auction market
theory,
that kind of stuff. So, let me break
this down for you actually. So, we are
at a So, we're in a We have a 7-week
profile. So, 7 weeks of overlapping
value means we have a 7-week profile.
We've also built out three
three days of balance here, so we have a
3-day profile.
Okay, so
we find this here. So, if we look at
this idea here,
we're rotational here, right? We we
attempt to break lower, we fail, price
accepts back inside of this now 3-day
profile,
traverses to the other side of value,
tries to break to the upside, sweeps
this high.
And then from there,
right? Price reverts back into value,
right? Retest the edge of value. So, now
it's shown acceptance. This is fair
value, and you expect to result to the
other side. So, where does order flow
come into play here? Well,
if we look here,
you can see that we have a large
increase in open interest with positive
delta.
Right? So, this is essentially new
buyers getting aggressive at what is
obvious resistance here. So, buyers are
buying into what is a retest of value
area high,
right? And that was kind of the local
top we put in before we traded down
lower.
So, you can identify that because
increase in open interest with positive
delta,
and that's this candle right here. You
can see we trade down from there.
And that's that. So,
that whole process of
positions being forced to close, and uh
the idea of that, that's what you'd call
a flip in the delta.
So, that's also identified by the same
cheat sheet. I'm going to pull it up one
more time just to show you.
Right? So, we have
a large increase in open interest with a
large amount of positive delta, and I
know this is very significant because of
the shading I have on it as well.
Right?
The next thing you'd see is a
so, increase in open interest,
positive delta means new longs.
Right?
Just put that over there.
Followed [clears throat] by
I know that longs are now forced to
close here, and I know that because we
see a decrease in open interest, a large
flush in open interest with negative
delta.
Right? So, decrease in open interest is
positions closing with negative delta,
that means longs are closing.
And that continues throughout this
entire downtrend.
So,
this immediate candle following, longs
are forced to close, and you can see
over this kind of uh
accumulation here, this is all positions
closing with pretty much all negative
delta. So, these are all longs being
forced to close on this grind down.
So, it would be a flip in the delta. So,
we go from positive delta,
right, in this candle to the following
one negative delta and then again as we
trend down lower, that would be negative
delta. That's a flip in the delta.
Okay, so that's the basics of
absorption.
Uh the next thing,
exhaustion. So, it's essentially doing
the opposite.
Um
it's essentially [clears throat] when,
you know,
the aggressive side of the market kind
of runs out of fuel. It runs out of
buyers or sellers. So,
um this can be identified kind of the
same way. So, let me pull this back up.
Except different context.
So, let's say price approaches a level
like resistance or support and there is
buyers and, you know, as
you know, let's say this is resistance,
it's trending upwards, you can see
buyers are participating.
As you approach the level kind of, you
know, longs start to close, starts to
kind of slowly unwind.
Right, and that can be a way to position
as well.
The reason this isn't as favorable is
because
there's no trapped positions to fuel the
move the other way.
Right, because the longs have decided to
close, it's just more likely that, okay,
we'll probably see some kind of a
reversal now. Doesn't mean you can't
position here, it's just a less
favorable sequence of order flow in
order to get yourself short.
I don't know if I have an example of
that, to be honest with you.
Um
off the top of my head here.
There's a lot of new positioning here,
it looks like.
So, yeah, I mean, another good example
here, right, this is all new positions
basically opening,
right, a lot of a lot of positive delta
at the highs here.
Then you can see they start to get
flushed out kind of through it here. So,
another good example of absorption
there, but I don't have
one of exhaustion.
But essentially, you would see the same
thing. So, for example, if if price was
approaching
resistance here.
Hit this level.
Right? You You start to see longs
unwind. So, maybe we you know we start
to kind of slow down. Price starts to
kind of range or you know slowly lose
its trend.
Um and then, you know, as it starts to
trend down, you'll see a decrease in
open interest with positive delta.
Or decrease in open interest with
negative delta rather, sorry. If it was
a you know, longs unwinding at
resistance.
The next thing worth noting
is flushes in open interest. So, this
would be kind of your second most
favorable thing to uh
position on in my opinion. So,
absorption would be first.
A flush or a squeeze in open interest
would be second and exhaustion would be
third in my opinion. So, there's some
really good examples of this actually
yesterday and today kind of
on just on Bitcoin here.
I can kind of show you the levels as
well and how AMT would fit into all of
this in profiling.
Uh so, where are we here?
I went over this earlier today. I think
we were here.
Let's just find it. I think it's here.
So, there's some really wonky kind of
price action here actually. So, let's
just see
where we were at.
So, this is kind of buyers getting
absorbed and then failing. But again,
context is always very important with
order flow. Like I said, you don't want
to get caught up staring at it if you
don't have the right read on the chart.
But more or less, right? You have
obvious resistance here.
Right? You can see my my cursor overlaps
here. So, we you know we buy into this
high like I mentioned.
A lot of fresh positioning, right?
Increase in open interest with positive
delta throughout this entire kind of
price action.
Right?
And then, you can see that
starts to dip lower. We get a flush in
open interest, right? You can see
decrease here, right? A lot of negative
delta upon this flush. Right? So,
there's a flush in open interest.
And uh you know, that's right around the
middle of the range here. Buyers take
another stab here as you can see. Open
interest is still increasing. It's still
basically all positive delta.
So, they try to push it up again.
And conversely, they fail again. So, big
flush there, right? Big decrease in open
interest, a lot of negative delta.
Right? Same thing this entire move down.
So, we get a big flush there.
And then at that point where you know,
we're back down at this um
3-day value area low. Right? Price
breaks below there. Buyers attempt to to
break back into value, right? So,
essentially
um
if it was going to remain rotational
here and
the market still agreed that you know,
this was fair price, you would you know,
you'd see something like this.
You'd see a shift back inside.
Right? And you'd see price start
trending back up. Of course, they were
unable to do that in value area low. Now
that price is outside of the range is
resistance, right? It's It's support
inside, it's resistance outside.
And And I know that's you know, new
buyers attempting to push it up again
because again, open interest is still
steadily increasing over this entire
bit of price action here. And it's
essentially you know, the majority of
that is positive delta.
And then again, there's going to be
another big flush, right? You see
another flush lower.
Big negative delta, big flush in OI.
And uh you know, even some more down
there. And I think it got flushed out
once more actually if we look here. I
think the you know, the exact same thing
actually happened.
Um
So, yeah. Increase in open interest
again. There's a bit more negative delta
here. Um
Buyers got a little bit more aggressive,
but not as clear as this. And then
again, another big flush in OI.
So,
um
Yeah, and then I think this probably
another flush here to be honest, right?
So,
more steady increase in OI. Some
negative delta, some sellers around here
as well, but there's still some buyers.
And then you can see another flush
there. Not a significant lower time
frame, but
So, why does this matter to you?
Well, above obvious areas, right? Highs
and lows where stop losses are, you'll
see often times you'll see you'll see a
squeeze or a flushing OI and that's off
you know, often times that can be your
inflection. So,
um let's just go to higher time frame
here. Which I I normally use this on a
lower time frame, but
let's just kind of take a look here what
we have.
Uh we have the high there. What else do
we have built out in this range?
Let's just go along here.
Uh where are we?
So, for example, let's just look at this
inflection here. I think this was
quarterly VWAP is where this was.
So, [clears throat] more often than not
almost every major inflection you're
either going to see a big flush in open
interest or a big increase in open
interest. So, essentially it's saying
is there somebody getting aggressive
where they probably shouldn't be or did
somebody just get flushed out of their
position and now the move's actually
going to happen is the way I like to
look at it. So,
right? You can see here this this is
there's there's buying into
into the highs here, right? So,
open interest is steadily increasing
here, especially on this like last leg
here, right? Lots of open interest, lots
of fresh positioning.
And you know, majority of it's positive
delta.
And then you can see from there the
longs start to unwind. So, price trends
down.
You can see the starts to decrease and
longs start to get flushed out. So,
being that a lot of this move is fueled
by new longs, right? You can see right?
This is steadily increasing. Majority of
this is positive delta. Longs start to
get flushed.
So,
and yeah, I just wanted to touch on
that. Really
simple way to read order flow. Very easy
the way I have this template set up. Um
very very useful. Like I said, I do use
footprint and and other data and a lot
more stuff, but
this is extremely useful for what it is.
So, hopefully you found this useful.